I forget that that's the theme song I
forgot oh because we're making frickin
money
Warren Sharpe in studio which means it's
even good immensely better get to hang
out last night got a little bit of meals
you eat some things that you haven't
eaten maybe in months or years but we're
not gonna tell anybody at home Oh
delicious
yeah so good the discipline that this
man has is crazy and that's why I like
spending time with him because his focus
on this stuff is crazy we have all of
the the Twitter open just in case
there's any practice reports I got tons
of notes about injuries and all that I
know you're paying attention right now
for example does it look like Cam
Newton's gonna play that's that's the
news that's coming out as we record this
Thursday early afternoon but that is the
theme of the week new quarterbacks that
are throwing a wrench in in all of the
models and systems that I'm sure that
you've been building it's we got like
seven new guys this week now six new
guys yeah it's super frustrating because
I more than anything I'm a fan of this
sport yes I want to see good football I
try to obviously I work with some teams
right but I also try to just publicly
share information that I think is going
to help these teams utilize so that the
product that we're watching uh Sunday's
is as efficient as it can possibly be
would you also say that better players
equals more trends and analytics that
are more reliable I find these guys that
the quarterbacks that are coming in the
the Rudolph's the Allens that the Fox
they're they're their wild cards so it
kind of ruins these games in a way yeah
they're more erratic they're less
reliable or less consistent right higher
highs lower lows sometimes some of these
guys and by that I mean it's relative
higher highs right I'm not saying that
they're gonna have like higher highs
than Patrick Mahone
right but like for them they're gonna
have some great games because the coach
prepared them really well for that spot
and then they're gonna have some games
where they
struggle and look like rookies or
first-year starters sure you so it's
it's it also muddies the overall trends
one of the things that I like to look
back at is what are the trends for the
league what's the league trending
towards and what we end up seeing when
something like this happens is we may
see a little bit more early down rushing
then I would prefer to see and the
league was trending away from that over
the first couple were the percentages I
mean we I don't know offhand what the
exact percentage was but they had
increased the passing rate on early
downs and I was like yes I sent out a
tweet about like yes we're getting
somewhere right we're actually passing
the football a little bit more we're
utilizing more 12 personnel you know
different trends like that where then
you lose some of these key players and
especially from the quarterback position
coaches are more likely to get more
conservative let their protects this
young play collar we're gonna run on
first we're gonna run on second
hopefully we get him like a third and
five and then we'll throw a screen yeah
totally yeah but the problem the problem
with that is they think that they're
helping these guys but they're actually
hurting them they're setting them up for
failure when you get too conservative
with your play calls on early downs so
one of them watch wait about the easiest
way is to pass the ball on first down
why because that's when the defense has
no clue what's coming they're typically
gonna be more so in base they're gonna
be looking to stop the run especially
with the first time starting quarterback
in there and that's a great look to pass
out of you you said this in your book
now for years if you get base on defense
on first down we're not running it right
in the gut because that's where the
defense is most prepared and we're also
not throwing it on the outside because
the percentages aren't good when they're
in base which is your typical year and a
4-3-3
linebackers we're not going nickel we're
not going to go we can focus on running
backs and tight ends with prime matchups
in the middle of the field
right so when I'm watching Mason Rudolph
I should be seeing him throw into James
Connor against San Francisco on Sunday
when I'm watching Luke Falk we need to
be focusing on levy on bail if we're
gonna survive this game against the
Patriots if I'm seeing Kyle Allen we
know they're giving them all to
Christian McCaffrey that that's the one
team I don't have to worry about going
early downs Chris McCaffrey's played a
hundred
snaps this year that's wild war yeah
they wanted to scale them back a little
bit out there but that's not gonna be
happening right and you you want to mix
up some of the running back passes you
don't want to get the worst thing to do
as an offense is get too predictable so
you want to vary things you want to
incorporate the tight ends in there you
want to be a little bit more creative
but what you can't do is be conservative
and unfortunately that's what I think a
lot of these coordinators do they say
well we don't want to load this guy up
too much we don't want to give him too
much to process yes we don't want to
give him too many reads and there's ways
like for instance why do you think Kyle
Shanahan why do you think his
quarterbacks last year even with Jimmy
Garoppolo going out he had to cycle
through a couple different quarterbacks
and they still had great efficiency
passing the football why is that because
he knows the way to design concepts and
routes that are going to be successful
more coaches that he's got quarterbacks
that have been injured and out need to
look to like study study some of what
Kyle Shannon was doing last year
implement those things I think more
teams and we're getting like all over
this is good more teams need to steal
concepts from other teams or from
college I don't care who owns it like
ownerships irrelevant utilize things to
make your team better the best play
colors are the best thieves and they'll
admit it
Sean Payton admits it Kyle Shanahan amid
said Sean McVeigh admits it very
willingly I mean the Patriots it's well
documented if Michigan the Patriots it
against the Ravens in the playoffs where
they watched Alabama put an eligible
tackle at the tackle spot and then catch
the ball across the middle and the next
day the Patriots used it you have to be
a good thief to get back to what you're
saying to use the information Mason
Rudolph
Teddy Bridgewater Kyle Allen Daniel
Jones Luke Falk if I know that we are
going to be getting possible
conservative play scripts that often
lead to negative results how much of a
benefit is there for me to bet against
these rookie teams like how do these
rookie quarterbacks how do I weigh that
knowing that they're gonna call they're
gonna be typically more conservative
okay so with with Kyle Allen and Mason
Rudolph
I would expect those teams to be to
Errol and and Luke Falk to air a little
bit more on the side of caution right
with those guys
teddy bridgewater is an interesting one
and we're gonna talk about his way
better right now well because we also
have another quarterback on that roster
right who's probably going to be
utilized more than other people think I
said this to you before the show and you
were saying this to me last night
that Sean Payton is one of those guys
that he's not going down without
shocking you in as many ways possible
and maybe hinting at that by saying we
might split with Taysom Hill and then
I'm on the train this morning and I'm
going
Sean Payton losing Drew Brees in a weird
way I know Sean Payton it's probably a
sick challenge in his head where he
wants to go you want to see how good I
am as a play caller wait until you see
this flea-flicker in the first quarter
wait until you see this Taysom Hill
screen back to camara like that's what
he does and so I could Sean Payton's
never gonna get conservative and Taysom
Hill is gonna be interesting
look what what is one of the knocks if
you have Drew Brees as your quarterback
and you're a guy like Sean Payton you
come up with all these things you don't
do you don't too many other people throw
on the ball because you got frickin Drew
Brees yeah but now you don't have true
please Sean Payton hasn't you know all
of his creativity can seep into this
offense unadulterated
mayhem offensively to confuse that
Seahawks defense and you know Drew was
in the meetings to go and I mean he's in
he's a coach at this point too
so I do have confidence in the Hoff and
and look Teddy Bridgewater this is a big
game for him when he is passing because
he looked like a total deer in
headlights when he got out onto the
field and when he had a really good
defense in Minnesota there were some
things that I actually thought were
pretty good with what he was doing but
you know this is a big game for him to
look well-prepared
you didn't mention Daniel Jones is this
because you believe Shermer has been
wanting this guy to be the guy the
entire time and Shermer is almost like
if I can make this work with Daniel
Jones
I might extend my life here in New York
by a year or two so let's get a little
wild yet Daniel Jones is the one that
you're right
when mentioning the other four because I
think they're gonna have some really
nice things designed up for Daniel Jones
do you remember when Daniel Jones played
the first preseason game Eli got the
first drive yes sir
Daniel Jones comes in the plays were all
so well thought out with Pat Shermer it
was boom boom boom I think five crossing
route and then a nice little roll out
and hit that guy in the back right
corner of the endzone but it was it
flowed it was like five plays that
flowed together exactly it well designed
well scripted easy for Daniel Jones to
read and execute and a touchdown and
then boom he was gone I think they're
really gonna be working on this game
plan to make life easy on Daniel Jones
how much can we buy and how much can you
look at the trends of his preseason
performances does that matter at all or
is that just to get us excited and and
realize it's a different season yeah I
in terms of like his pure statistics I
don't look quite as much at that as what
do you look like in the pocket it's like
like the visual your eye test does this
guy look like he can be an NFL
quarterback and to me he did to me he
looked like he was confident enough in
the pocket now that's not against the
defense that's game planning for you
that's not you know a super tough
opponent that is starting to try to
figure out your waste the whole time
right so it's gonna be a different
scenario in this game but I absolutely
you know think that he should be able to
handle it and the Bucs I mean I think I
think it could be a good spot we were
talking about that a little bit last
night yeah just about the fact that they
have Shaquille Barrett was a pretty good
pass rusher but other than that they
haven't really gotten after the
quarterback too much I mean Cam Newton
was under a lot of pressure and and I
think I'm just kind of confused what's
going on with Carolina at all right now
so it's kind of hard and especially on a
short week with all that and then also
don't forget they're like a 45-minute
lightning delay and people are glossing
over the fact that Carolina was looking
really good before that and then all of
a sudden it kind of ended there was a
fourth down play that kind of stopped
the momentum and that's something you
have to factor and I I think about it
may have been two years ago there was a
Tampa Bay Rams game that had like a
three hour or may have
dolphins Titans came last year or there
was like a three-hour lightning game a
delay and everyone's trying to use that
game I'm like this I can't even use this
game for anything this is such a special
circumstance doesn't matter that Luke
that that game the Carolina game this
time out against the Bucks
you know Thursday night less on Thursday
night last week I am just this very firm
believer in a concept that I noticed
with Cam Newton and that is that he's a
front-runner in my view and by that I
mean he if things start going well in
games it snowballs in a good way for him
and he gets more confidence I've heard
this from players I talk to Gerald McCoy
about this and he said that the hardest
thing about cam is when he starts
rolling he is talking more than anybody
in the stadium that's when you see him
get up and do this every time he goes
back to line of scrimmage and he goes
cam gets better when he's talking [ __ ]
so players on the field are confirming
what you're seeing statistically yeah I
mean and and so what I think happened in
that game right before the lightning
delay they didn't have good camera
angles because for some reason I've
annoyed what the NFL is doing here how
you say it's not safe for our cameramen
to be there but it is safe for the fans
to watch in the stands and the players
to play on the field but like our
cameramen can't be in harm's way here
but in either case they were playing the
game and it was the fourth and one he
rolls out to the right get the knees
knocked out from underneath the stretch
stretches it could have been a first
down I mean the the the team thinks that
he got jobs on that one they'd gotten
job Don a few calls the Carolina
Panthers have let's be let's be honest
yeah but at any rate doesn't get it boom
lightning delay sit in for 30 minutes in
the locker room 16 about how you got
your knees knocked out from under you
and you didn't get the first down and
that's exactly what you know Cam Newton
what how it hurts him when he when he's
not rolling when he's not having that
confidence and he has to think about it
for a while I think it messed them up
the rest of the game and that sounds so
subjective and not analytical but that
is something that I am a firm believer
of when you knock cam around early in
that game he doesn't get rolling you got
a really good look like what you see
with Bill O'Brien if he's got a UH if
he's losing at halftime it's it's shown
that there
coming back that's not who he is the
fact that all six of these quarterbacks
are playing on the road what does that
say to you
even higher likelihood that the coaches
you're gonna go in with a conservative
you might like let's not lose this game
with the exception with the exception of
Sean Payton because I think we'll talk
about that game later but I'm I'm
interested in that game so I want to
take some of the things we talked about
in week two and the only way that we're
gonna improve the 33 percent myself
everybody out there is we need to look
at what we said and learn from it the
thing that kills me about a lot of
betting shows and a lot of betting sites
is they put out their winners and then
they never go back and talk about it the
amount like if you go to odd shark you
can't pull up what their predictions
were in week two and now I don't I don't
go that I used to go there all the time
and I go well let me see how they've
been doing picking the Bucs and then I
can't go back and because it's not good
for business to go over your losses but
here's the deal we're not running a
[ __ ] business we're trying to help
people and so I want to look at the
things we talked about last week and
learn from them it's the only way we're
gonna get [ __ ] better at this so the
one thing we talked about a lot last
week was your personnel groupings
Baltimore Arizona what we talked about
was that Baltimore showed against Miami
when they went three or more wide
receivers they were susceptible was
Arizona able to take advantage of that
when you went back and looked at the
statistics yeah they were Arizona from
11 personnel okay that's three wide
receivers spreading out that defense
taking advantage of them
64 percent success rate twelve point
eight yards per attempt LA and a 115
passer rating against the Baltimore
Ravens defense and this is one of the
reasons why we were talking about that
we think the Cardinals offense may look
a little bit better than people think
they may be able to be productive here
now we were using that for like a couple
of elements right the first one was the
total and the second one was the
Cardinals plus the 13 right and so for
that reason we were thinking like both
of those recommendations could be in our
benefit and you know they the Cardinals
averaged
only from 12 personnel only a 25 percent
success rate in seven yards per attempt
now they don't just more Ravens cover
perfectly exactly they're really good
take the wide receivers off the field
you throw to your tight end your running
backs we've got speed up in the front we
can deal with that you know they're down
Shore the secondary short hand Jimmy
Smith out yeah right so we thought that
there was going to be some edges there
and sure enough what the Arizona
Cardinals had four or five drives to the
red zone one conversion want one
touchdown so I know they kicked three
field goals inside the five and and and
that was like obviously surprising from
a Kliff Kingsbury coach because you
think he's going to be if anything more
aggressive right you would think that he
would be the kite type of coach who's
like I don't give a crap about this like
let me let me go for the touchdown
because even those first two drives they
get down there inside the five kick two
field goals ad they scored just one
touchdown go for it one thought once on
fourth down you convert one of them
you'll wind up with more points than you
would if Oh settle for one of those
became a touchdown we're hitting our /
if the Ravens don't kneel inside the
five riding are over you know what I
just realized as you were saying that I
don't think Kliff Kingsbury is
aggressive I think Kliff Kingsbury is
aggressive in terms of formations he
uses but think about what we see now the
last two weeks non aggressive play
calling inside the five which has led to
field goals not going for it on fourth
down what do we see in week one him
punting the ball with one minute left in
overtime and settling for a tie in my
mind I'm starting I'm not saying it yet
but I'm starting to notice cliff is
aggressive in his scheme but I don't
think he's aggressive in his situational
play calling
this isn't Doug Peterson here we assume
that all young people are aggressive
because young people are aggressive with
how they invest they take to invest in
stocks they don't invest in mutual funds
we but he's not am I crazy am I going
too far no look I mean and the part
about it is that they kicked those three
field goals they put up nine points then
they have to go for the touchdown late
in the game they score it and then they
go for the two-point conversion because
they're forced to to get to separating
points to get you know within the the
score margin and they end up making that
that conversion so he's got plays that
would work there right he's got it's not
like
we think we suck down here so we're not
gonna we're just going to be
conservative
he's got plays that could work but
you're right from a decision-making
perspective and an understanding of the
analytics and what is the risk reward of
making a more aggressive play call here
I don't think he's got the right
analytics in his corner to help him make
educated decisions and then the other
thing that we saw in that game and I
just wanna do this briefly was
Baltimore's heavy sets should work
wonders against Arizona and I'm sure
that was the case
- yeah Baltimore had a lot of success
with that now what was interesting is
you know Arizona did a surprising good
job taking away some of those shot plays
right they didn't have as much success
down the field as they did had the 30
plus sherrod Mark Andrews touchdown
there the Hollywood Brown past seal it
to seal it over the top right and that
was Lamar Jackson running it was a lot
more it was a lot more to Lamar Jackson
running because and they weren't
necessarily designed runs either it was
decent coverage so he took off and ran
the ball so you know what props to
Arizona the fact that you can say decent
coverage with Robert Alford and Patrick
Peterson out on the field I it was a
little bit of the Vance Joseph because I
was ready to kill him after week one no
III 100% concur that they were so sloppy
that week they did better than I
anticipated from that perspective the
frustration about this game of course I
bet the over we talked about it on the
show and the line moved all the way up
to 47 and we took over 43 the
frustration of course is the red zone
ineptitude those eight combined trips
into the red zone only two touchdowns
these are the types of games that we're
exactly what you said you have to sit
back and dig through whom the box score
the film to understand was I completely
wrong right with my bet on this game
with my anticipation of what was going
to happen or was I accurate and the ball
just bounced a ridiculous way too often
such that it didn't come through and in
this case this was a dead nut over game
there's no two ways about it when you're
eight trips down into the red zone and
you're only scoring two touchdowns
that's the only way this game did not go
over
is redzone success and ineptitude
something that can be transferred from
week to week and used with confidence
you mean like is if a team struggles or
the future
yeah like is that something that that
tends to continue um I think there's
always going to be a little bit of
regression it is more difficult when
you're an offensive play caller calling
plays down in that limited areas feel
because you're used to stretching out
with four wide receivers right the
defense doesn't have to cover as much
depth wise so everything's more
compressed and it is a little bit easier
on the defenses however it should be it
should allow enough creativity for an
offense to utilize the width of the
field and try to create openings and
seams and we just didn't we just didn't
get lucky enough in that game it was we
were very unlucky uh you also had a
thing last week about Cleveland's
obsession with 11 personnel and Freddie
kitchens last year Unleashed Baker
Mayfield by going heavy sets protect him
a little bit more and taking advantage
Monday night in Joe cou concussion we
now learn breaks his wrist does this
mean we're gonna get a lot LA and
Rashard Higgins's back what did you see
on Monday night and does this mean that
Cleveland's gonna be sitting in 11 for
like the next four to five weeks with a
joke on the bench because they're not
really trying to bring out Rickey seals
Jones too much I think unfortunate we
are gonna see too much of 11 and what is
this is something we could take
advantage of yeah the this is the thing
and this is why I don't think we dug
into it quite as much why Freddie
kitchens went more to 12 last season one
of the reasons why he went more to 12
when he took over is because of the
protection protection it afforded Baker
Mayfield in the pocket when he's
throwing the ball so far this season
Baker Mayfield has a 40 passer rating
when he's under pressure and what he'll
do so that one more time
Baker Mayfield this season when he's
under pressure including Monday night's
game so the first two weeks a 40 passer
rating a passer rating of 40 Wow when
he's under pressure which is obviously
terrible it's one of the worst in the
NFL so you're gonna get when you have a
worse offensive line
which they do they lost players this
offseason we knew going into the season
they were going to have a worse
offensive line and you don't utilize a
little bit more 12 to get those tight
ends out on the field to at least give
the threat that you can block the front
and or to at least make that d-end work
a little bit harder to get around the
outside and this is one of the I'll
finish the point then I'll transition
into something else this is this is a
problem because without those tight ends
out there
I think the pass rush is coming it's
affecting Baker Mayfield and in some
cases it affects the quarterback before
the snap he knows what type of
protection he knows that that I've got
five linemen I see this defense here
before the balls even snapped he starts
worrying about where where's the leak
gonna come through and guess who's
coming to town Aaron frickin Donald so
it's a and and Dante Fowler is playing
like he's a third pick in the draft
he looks like a different guy and so
you're telling me
Aaron Donald's coming to town and Baker
has a 40% is a 40 QB rating under okay
yeah and the this this is this next
point that I was gonna make we saw the
LA Rams struggle with this very same
thing in the Super Bowl in that Super
Bowl the New England Patriots remember
how often they were getting to Jared
Goff and hitting him early in the game
and that offense looked out a sink and
they couldn't do anything because they
kept sending pressure when LA even
though they did not love their two tight
ends right they did not love their tight
end so that's why they were hesitant to
use them but when they stuck them on the
field even though they're not great in
Pass Pro that's when they had their most
success in the Super Bowl a passing you
know one of the guys will get bowled
over by the D end on the way to the
quarterback but guess what it still
takes an extra second or two for that to
occur so it provides the quarterback a
little bit extra timing if that guy if
that tight end wasn't because he makes
like two more steps two more steps have
to physically exert himself have to like
step over the guy that he knocked over
and the quarterback then has that extra
second he needs for the receiver to
separate better and complete that ball
and Jared Goff had a lot of success so
even though you don't like your two
tight ends yes sometimes having that
extra body out there will help your wide
receivers
that to me is some of the most valuable
[ __ ] you've said Minnesota Green Bay
this was a personnel trend you noticed
from last year this is what the game was
week two and I want to see if it
continued because everyone's talking
right now about how the Packers defense
is completely different and I kind of
agree with what they've been able to
bring in with a MOS and the two mister
mister Smith at the edges what we've
seen at a green baize defense thus far
has been the success we were hoping for
with Lafleur and the Rogers offense
Penton right now is throwing himself
into the head coaching mix but how good
of a job he's doing on DC but your issue
was Green May was the worst defense the
NFL last year with Mike Benton against
to wide receiver sets heavy formations
was Minnesota able to use that at all I
know they had the one deep touchdown the
Stefon Diggs I believe that was with two
eye receivers on the field correct but
it was what else happened what did it
have same issues so Green Bay across the
board is a better defense than they were
last year they were also better equipped
to handle the two tight end sets and
front when they were in 12 personnel one
running back to tight ends two wide
receivers Minnesota got nine point five
yards attempt which is which is a nice
number which is a nice number but only a
42 percent success rate so a couple of
big strikes yes but not quite as
consistently successful but against 11
personnel Green Bay defending 11
personnel yeah
22 percent success rate so they still
were much worse defending those two
tight end sets but they were better than
they were last year against it and they
were very good just like there were last
year at defending three wide receivers
my big question for you is this if you
see that Green Bay does not have success
against 21 or 12 meaning 2i receiver
sets when I'm betting the game how do I
know that the other team is good to take
advantage of that is it by the amount
that they use that personnel like how do
I know that we see a hole right now how
do I know this other team is gonna take
advantage of it yet that's the thing
week there's a fallacy amongst everybody
who watches games and I'm not trying to
suggest
I'm smarter than anybody else but
there's a fallacy of rational coaching
rational coaching is not always
prevalent in the NFL any sport I mean
it's difficult these coaches focus on so
many different things their job is tough
they're not always optimizing everything
offensively we assume that they're going
to take advantage of all the holes but
that's not always the case and what
happens is we watch the games play out
on Sunday and we blame the players right
oh man what an interception what the
hell's this guy doing all this guy
dropped a touchdown right the Eagles
down the sideline regular regular why
the hell did you drop that that would
have won the game
it's Aguilar you know all these
different things that we look at we
pinpoint on the different players the
reality is sometimes the coaches don't
have a very good game plan in this game
so what I look at first and foremost
when it comes to those personnel
groupings is I'm looking at that
frequency what is the historic trend of
this offense because I know that
typically speaking they're going to
continue to do that so when a team
utilizes a lot of 11 personnel I assume
that they're probably going to continue
doing that if a team you so I can't
assume for instance that the Cleveland
Browns are gonna all of a sudden switch
and go to 12 personnel even though they
used it last year because this year they
got Odell Beckham and this seems to be
their strategy now maybe at some point
they'll smarten up and switch but until
I actually see that I'm not I'm not just
gonna go oh yeah look at this defense
against 12 they're terrible so I think
Freddy kitchens gonna use a ton of 12
here because I haven't seen him do that
yet so I can't assume it's go let me ask
you I am put on your spot I know you're
have to look up something really quick
Denver are they an offense that uses to
wide receiver sets or are they someone
that wants to load out with Noah Fant
and maybe Lindsey and Royce Freeman in
the back is there are they a team that
plays that kind of way the Denver
Broncos actually utilize a lot of 11
personnel they're at 78% 11 personnel
when they pass so this is a great
example of the Packers are great against
11 and the Broncos are playing almost
80% 11 with Joe Flacco and while
Emmanuel Sanders is is a medical marvel
the fact that he's able to perform I am
not afraid of him beating gyre Alexander
anywhere on the field like not even a
blat like a chance
so I'm looking at this I'm going Wow how
the hell are the Broncos gonna score
against the Packers well it's fair and
Plus which when they do use 12 personnel
to pass the ball right which is Green
Bay's better against 12 than last year
but it's still their weak point Denver
has five point five yards per attempt
when just very low which is very low
they don't throw out of it much right we
talked about 87% on 78 percent rather 11
personnel so they don't throw out a 12
gosh but when they do so far this year
not so good I the thing is is those that
number is what eight and a half so I'm
like that for Green Bay seven and a half
I'm seeing man it's just Vegas is really
good at knowing to throw a number at you
that scares you it's always the half
point that gets me warren is there
anything else I just want to ask a
blanket statement from week 3 personnel
groupings that sticks out to you is
there anything that kind of excited you
as you were going through the team
matchups yeah yeah there was two things
that relate to the future of some of the
things we're going to talk about Road so
I won't dive hardcore and did this want
this this first one which is Kansas
City's usage of 11 personnel let's talk
about that wave ins yeah we do the three
big games when we do the three big games
but I will talk about this Carolina
Arizona game okay that's about to happen
because we weren't going to talk about
it we weren't going to talk about that
but from the personnel groupings so far
with two weeks of data some interesting
trends here Arizona's defense has been
really good against three wide receiver
sets okay they have allowed and this is
Detroit played them yeah in Baltimore
played them with both of them like to do
this both of them like to both of those
teams are very will use 12 will use 21
will use some 11 okay and there's a
stark contrast to what Arizona could do
defending 11 versus 12
Arizona against three wide receivers 36
percent success rate only five point
nine yards per attempt and very
importantly five sacks in 74 drop backs
okay but when you use multiple tight
multiple running backs you take a
receiver off the field you only use two
wide receivers or fewer yeah when you
pass the ball against Arizona's defense
68 percent success rate so up from 36%
11.5 yards per attempt over double the
5.9 and importantly zero sacks Wow
now what does Carolina do well yeah what
do they do they don't do well throwing
the ball with three wide receivers out
on the field they only have a 40%
success rate so far this year only four
point nine yards per attempt and they
themselves have taken five sacks but
when they take that extra wide receiver
off put on an extra running back or
tight end typically it's a tight end for
them right fifty-two percent success
rate eleven point four yards per attempt
a 1:05 rating and only one sack so are
you in his Carolina what is their
percentage of going twelve or twenty one
versus 11
Carolina is a little bit more balanced
but so far this season last year they
they were even more balanced but so far
this season they've gotten 78% just like
we mentioned with Denver
yeah 78% 11 personnel when they pass the
ball they are going to need especially
with a yeah court backup quarterback out
there it is imperative that the Carolina
Panthers use less three wide receiver
sets use more 12 personnel I wish there
was a way that like we could watch the
team's warm up and in pregame and be
like look at all the 12 and 21 they're
lining up and like it it's like when
you're go to a horse race and you look
at the horses I just want a chance to
see the offense really quick because if
Carolina if I know that Carolina is
gonna run it to a ton of 12 and 21 it
feels like a great bet but it's yeah I
can't how do I know Warren how do I know
right and the issue is twofold number
one do the coaches know this mm and then
number two will they modify anything
even if they did know it so that's what
you have to factor in and that's why
trying to predict these games what we
can't say we we obviously at the end of
the day our place in wager is trying to
help the 33 percent of place wagers at
the end of day we're fortune tellers
we're trying to prognosticate the future
yeah and with something where there's 53
men you have no idea who's going to get
injured you
you have a whole staff of coaches and
you don't know exactly what they're
going to do and you got a football
that's not a round ball right lots of
different things can happen in a game
and that's why you got to study all
these things because the outcome just
because the final score happens a
certain way does not notice you mean the
game played out that way and that's the
team that should have won the game so
it's hard predicting this type of stuff
and one of the hardest things I have
found because I'm I'm really good I dig
through so many numbers I could figure
out what I think the edges are here
the trick is are the is the coaching
staff actually going to makes changes
modification or still you're still
betting on human decisions yes and
that's even harder to predict than the
balance of the ball
all right so line movements I went
through and looked in week two lines
that changed by more than a point and a
half compared to the look-ahead lines
went three and five against the spread
for the team that it went to but two of
those games were the Browns
where they went the Jets lost two
quarterbacks and the Patriots and the
Dolphins so in my mind it's like one in
five in like real games where when the
Houston went from a three point favorite
of Jacksonville to a nine didn't cover
Cincinnati went from an underdog to a
favorite didn't cover Baltimore like
nine to thirteen didn't cover Chicago
pick him into an F didn't cover Philly
so in there so that was because this is
the first time that I've really looked
at it so when the points went to the
team which we've talked about is an
overreaction from what we saw on Sunday
in almost all of these situations it was
too much other than a two quarterbacks
going down the only one that covered was
Buffalo and that was the only other one
that actually covered and we were all
over that just being you were definitely
all over that I know you gave that one
out on shark football analysis calm as
the money line there because you saw in
week one you throw foreigners that you
have four turnovers and you still win
and now you're playing in the same
stadium against Eli let's [ __ ] go but
is that accurate is that something that
I can kind of look at going forward
that's that's why we're looking at to
look at lines yeah and I'm glad you're
tracking it and we should continue to do
so because that's the whole point of us
breaking down those look-ahead lines
is what is the overreaction and
typically a lot of times it's the
bookmaker reacting a little bit and then
it's the betting public right continuing
to pile on to that overreaction so I
have three kind of sections again that
I'm going to do first one is a Wow which
is the look at headline from Miami
Dallas was Dallas - nine and now it's
Dallas - 21 and a half is this the first
time in history we have two 20-point
lines in the same week I think it's it
hasn't happened since like 30 years and
last week again I did not bet Miami last
week thank God I took it off Friday
night I was texting with crack and I
said nope can't do it
Patriots were the first team to ever be
favored by sixty and a half points on
the road win and cover so we did which
witness history last week but with two
lines over 20 how should the 33%
approach these games cautiously you know
what you have to do is figure out
motivation for the teams that are the
underdogs that game the Patriots game
against the Dolphins a lot of people
probably surprised at how close that
game was in 1360 nothin or halftime
something like that yeah and then of
course you get the multiple defensive
touchdowns and what did we talk about
what I write about in my book what did
we talk about this offseason that I
actually thought that this year the
Patriots offense might be carried more
so by that defense because I didn't know
Josh Gordon was there and I didn't know
Antonio Brown was gonna be there and we
knew Gronk was missing and we knew the
ride wide receivers that they had were
in and out of the lineup in the
offseason with injuries and ailments and
things like that right and but I had
very high confidence in that Patriots
defense they came to town scored a
couple of times and then named
themselves so you know that's a factor
when you're playing the Miami Dolphins
now I don't think the Dallas Cowboys
defense is quite as good as the newing
the Patriots so we may not have those
defensive scores on the other the other
game you know the New England sorry the
the New York Jets game Patriots against
the Patriots I think Luke Falk is a good
thing
as much tape on him he's a little bit
more of a wild card I think that that
Jets defense is still proud this is a
rival you know I would expect them to
play really tough but there's question
marks I think that if I don't
necessarily love what I think in the
super contest really like 22 and a half
yes if you had 23 23 and a half I might
be a little bit more especially if you
got up to 24 like a little bit more
inclined to test that I'm not saying
you're wrong if I choose to utilize that
game but it wouldn't take that many more
points for me to start looking at the
Jets this week but the Dolphins
I don't really have a lot of interest I
I can't do anything with the Dolphins
great note here from Engler who kind of
went through all the matchups the total
has gone under in five of the last a
five of the last five Patriots Jets
games so when I hear an under and then I
hear a line of 23 and a half like or
excuse me 21 and a half or whatever it
is with the it is what is that line
officially in the super contest 22 and
when it yeah you got 20 you're going
under and you have to win by 23 points
that sounds kind of crazy to me it does
and that's why you know when you talk
about correlation and things of that
nature
you got a really low total and you got a
really high spread on the dog I mean
that's that's indicating like if you can
if you can score you know 13 yeah 14 16
points maybe like you got a real good
chance of covering this game now there
are I have four games here that crossed
a key number Carina key numbers of
course everybody is 3/7 if it goes
across zero is crazy which you you tell
me which of these actually interest you
the most Indy went from a four point
favorite in a look ahead to a one and a
half point favorite hosting Atlanta so
Atlanta
I guess wins the game against the Eagles
Indy pulls one out the line has gone
from Colts favored by four to now one
and a half so across the three Oakland
is going to Minnesota Minnesota was a
seven point favorite they're now an
eight and a half point favorite out of
that's crossing a number but it just it
went from seven to eight and a half
Minnesota
I guess survived but I guess that's more
Oh
Glenn gets their ass kicked by the
Chiefs and people are starting to lose
confidence and we do have injuries to
Josh Jacobs and Trent Brown missed a
little bit that game to Philly goes from
an eight point favorite hosting the
Lions to now a six point favorite so
across the seven and we have a ton of
injury with the Philadelphia Eagles all
over the place so much so that they
cancel practice on Wednesday and just
held a walkthrough and the other one is
Monday night Chicago goes from a two and
a half point favorite to a four point
favorite against Washington so that did
cross the three of those for any of
those line movements catch your eye the
most well two that I know are like
syndicate money the Atlanta Falcons
playing the Colts and the Detroit Lions
playing the Eagles syndicate money
that's that's betting groups have moved
on those games pushed the numbers to
where they currently sit you know very
sharp betting groups so there's been
betting groups and have loaded up early
on Atlanta and Detroit they are seeing
weakness in Indy coming off to road
games at home for the first time their
home opener and Philadelphia with all
the injuries Sunday night game and and
Detroit coming off and so when you see
another syndicate go your first thought
is they must have really liked that
number and then do you check it to see
if your numbers matched up - yeah I mean
I pretty much already know what I like
and that's the reality of being in this
game this world is can I beat these
other guys to the lines because a lot of
us have the same ideas about different
teams we know which games that we like
more than or less than the bookmaker
right and so we want to try to be the
first to get those games so for example
using a game last week cuz we don't know
where these things are gonna close
getting the over 43 in Baltimore and the
game closes a 46 you know that's a
three-point value through some key
numbers right a 44 short and 45 and 43
is actually a pretty key number two
that's tremendous value so when you're
able to beat the closing number when
you're able to beat the closing number
that's like a big feather in your cap a
lot of guys a lot of the Sharps
ports betting groups that I work with
they they obviously want to win but if
you're beating the closing line and
you're having some losses they don't
actually care all that much they get
frustrated that the losses aren't coming
in but they know it'll even out because
what they care more so about is are you
getting on the right side of the number
are you guys that's the value that's
because this whole proposition is about
value so that I almost think of it to
equate it to the sneaker market there is
the resell value and then there's the
initial value and the people that get
the first Kobe's or the first LeBrons or
the first Jordans that come out are
people that are very well connected they
get sent them for free those are the
syndicates and then everybody else has
to go on stock X now working with
bleacher report and get the resale value
so when I see these lines move and I
just talked about how there's value
there I'm kind of going against the
syndicates but am I myself getting value
like I have circled and I'll talk about
this later the super contest India - one
and a half because I also saw that it
was at four so it went down to Atlanta
like it's favoring Atlanta now by two
and a half points and I see a lot of
holes in Atlanta I see a lot of injuries
in Atlanta does it now give me value the
other way that the syndicates kind of
gave me a team maybe that I already
liked yeah okay the thing you have to
realize about syndicators the 33% is the
resellers so I'm trying to help them out
on the the second mark right so the
issue is that depending on the syndicate
like we know behind the scenes who I
work with we know which guys run the
different groups right that bet enough
to move the betting market right they're
putting enough volume in there that
that's why these lines are writing and
so some of those guys you respect more
than others because some of them have a
little bit higher success over the long
haul that's what it's all about it's
about the long haul short term
I mean look some of these betting groups
go on runs or seasons where they lose in
an entire sport they come back the next
year fire and just as strong because
they know long term they're gonna win
fifty four fifty five percent and you
all you got to do is hit over fifty two
point four percent and you're going to
win on
is ten so that's what these guys are
doing mine is 10 you know - 110 Jews so
in some cases yes you will get a better
number when those guys fire do you want
to be against them frequently probably
not a good idea
however these guys are like 55 57% like
on good seasons and so there's still a
45 45 percent chance 43 45 percent
chance that they're going to be wrong on
this particular game and getting a
better number then it's maybe you know
it's it's not the worst thing trust me
when I have enough confidence in my
numbers that when if I like something
and they bet the wrong way I'm actually
feeling good mmm the worst thing is when
I like something and they like it and
they beat me to it
I feel bad then I feel good if I really
feel strongly and they for some reason
don't and I'm gonna get a better number
two lines moved and for me it's all
about performance based Cincinnati at
Buffalo buffalo the early line was
Buffalo by four it's now Buffalo by six
people are seemingly coming around the
Buffalo now I think that's what happens
when you play the New York market twice
you get a lot of attention for Josh
Allen so a lot of the value if you like
the bills which I did a lot goes from
four to six and the other one is the
Chargers were five and a half point
favorites hosting Houston and now
they're just three point five rates and
that one's really juicy to me because if
you're gonna be disappointed that the
Chargers lost an alliance they had the
reverse of having to pick sixes you know
they had the the touchdowns taken away
from them and to me that's like one of
those box scores that I'm actually
talking myself into it right now where I
don't think people actually watch that
game they just saw Phillip Rivers throw
an interception at the end of the game
and go oh wow they're actually not that
good and I go you guys just saw Houston
score 13 against Jacksonville so I'm
convincing myself but to me it looks
like Buffalo lost a lot of value and I'm
seeing a lot of value gained right now
for the Chargers well absolutely Buffalo
I mean look you I've been on the bills
the last two weeks big-time big-time
love them in those spots
and I one of the reasons why I stuck
with them the second week against the
Giants was because everybody looked at
the way that that score was playing out
they just see the score updates not that
they were down 15 nothing they got lucky
to come back and win that one exactly
now many people are actually watching
the game seeing all the interception so
when you dig into all that stuff when
you're watching the game I'm like man
well maybe we're gonna get some good
value next week and sure enough we did
get some good now you that next week but
we're not getting that good value this
week against Cincinnati so you have to
know when to you know steer clear of
something get off of something it
doesn't mean I mean look you could even
like the Bengals this week because we're
betting numbers and we're betting
situations we're not betting teams like
I could I could stocks we don't you hear
people say if you like a team to win you
should bet them to cover you go that's
crazy
that's that's yeah no no I've heard that
my entire life Warren no that's
absolutely not the way I mean look in
certain situations there's a high
correlation between the the times that
this team's gonna win and actually cover
the spread but you have to look at the
the points and the value that you're
getting in these situations and I mean
look I've been one of the biggest
critics of Matt Patricia Wright and I
was on you know I the the Lions that
week I was in a teaser I took the lines
as part of a team last week so I was
happy that they ended up winning us but
you know just because I don't like Matt
Patricia doesn't mean that there's not
value taking seven points with them when
they're in Philadelphia I mean there are
situations where I like a team I have
feelings about a team and I'll still bet
against teams that I like and I'll bet
on teams that I don't like based upon
the line and the value that I see
inherent in that number and then the
next week I might be completely on the
opposite side hmm okay uh you ready talk
about the three biggest games of the day
yeah let's start off with the big one
Ravens at Chiefs this is the game of the
day to to know teams the two two of the
four leading candidates for MVP as we're
two games through both quarterbacks have
two of the top three quarterback ratings
they also both have two seven touchdowns
zero interceptions Lamar Jackson just
ran for a hundred and twenty yards
patric mom's almost threw for 300 yards
in the second quarter alone it is a one
o'clock game according Ingrid's notes
here the Ravens are five and one against
the spread in their last six road games
injury-wise
it looks like Eric Fisher is not going
to play Cameron Irving is gonna play in
there instead of him also Jimmy Smith is
likely out which you've talked about the
splits before in terms of people that
did not practice Kansas City's running
backs were banged up
LeSean McCoy with an ankle Damian
Williams with a knee for the Ravens mark
Andrews is not practicing but this is a
note he did not practice on Friday and
he did play against Arizona the only
other did not practice that's
interesting to me is the full-back
Patrick Ricard he also plays defensive
tackle and for a team that uses a lot of
the fullback that's something to note do
you know what do you remember what the
Jimmy Smith splits are for the Ravens
defense off hand by any chance I could
look him up I don't remember them just
being drastic oh it's it's it was night
and day different it was it was we saw
last week mostly in the league
yes so my first question is this to go
back to what we learned from Baltimore
Arizona Baltimore has a problem with
three right three wide receivers they're
playing Patrick mahomes and that team
and they have running back issues what
are we about to see from that that that
sort of personnel meeting okay and by
the way last season just look them up
here because I searched through my
tweets I tweeted this out with Jimmy
Smith they were number four defending
passes in success rate number one in
interception rate and number one in
passer rating without Jimmy Smith number
29 in success rate which dropped from
number four number 31 in interception
rate has dropped from number one and
number 18 in passer rating which dropped
from number one now that was the the two
prior years they did a little bit better
in the couple games they missed him last
year but that was a very small sample
size so yeah not not great obviously but
the interesting thing about what you
just were talking about which
those three wide receiver sets and this
is what I was hinting at earlier when we
were talking about personnel groupings
nobody I think is talking about this
it's something I talked about a lot last
year was how much the Chiefs used 12
personality right they used a lot of 12
personnel last year okay
however because it was Ian Harris and
Travis Kelce and this year no this year
they're not using nearly as much 12
they're using a lot more 11 well Damien
Harris went to the Browns so listen to
these splits interesting last year
they passed the ball from 11 only 63
percent of the time and 28 percent of
the time from 12 28 percent one of the
highest rates in the league that's
really high from 12 this season 63% from
Levin has gone up to 85 percent from 11
and 28% from 12 has dropped down to 9%
those are major personnel shifts and
they don't even have Tyreke Hill this is
even without Tyreke Hill they're still
using a lot more 11 what is what do you
the patriot what did the Ravens struggle
to defend Wow
the Ravens struggled to defend you're
hurting my heart 12 the Ravens guy I
mean 11 personnel they are really good
defending 12 Chiefs are gonna use more
11 here probably now that game against
Oakland was weird last week right
because they got shut down the first
quarter shut out the third and fourth
quarter what are the Chiefs going to
look like over the course of the entire
game
Andy Reed is so good this month the
first month of the season in September I
think he's like perfect against the
spread perfect win-loss record last
several years so he's really good this
time of year where he's focused when he
he knows what he's got out of his team
I'm not saying I like the chiefs to
cover this I'm just sharing points of
observation that a lot of people at
least people who followed me know that I
have been talking a lot about the Chiefs
use a lot of 12 personnel but I need to
note to the 33% that that has changed
this season what about the fact because
you tweeted this earlier this week that
Patrick mahomes a success in the red
zone is so starkly worse in the first
two games this year than it was last
year and the fact that I just watched
Baltimore allow big place to
Arizona and then stop them as we
complained about last week three times
inside the five
also I went and looked while you were
talking earlier when Kansas City played
Baltimore last year all of Kansas City's
big plays were between the 20s
none of them scored so what Baltimore
it's a bend but don't break biggest play
the game last year 48 yard pass to
Tyreke Hill got down to the 12 the other
plays they got to the 43 or to the 24
these were not plays that scored and so
my question is is if Kansas City is able
to have some success is Patrick mahomes
his lack of success in the red zone
could it still keep it close like what
are you seeing in that part of the field
yeah it definitely could patrick mahomes
is a freak but what I've seen the first
couple of weeks from Patrick mahomes is
these ridiculous passes against pressure
in some cases thrown across this body
that have been big plays for the Chiefs
but in the red zone they have struggled
and that's explained some of their like
lack of consistency it's it's a small
super small sample size and the Jaguars
have a good defense but only 23% of his
red zone passes graded as successful so
far this year that's shocking
that's 27th in the league he was a 52%
last year almost twice as successful
when he passed in the red zone that was
number one in the league last year so
number one down at number 27 they were
the number one red zone offense in terms
of conversion rate touched scoring
touchdowns last year this year I mean
it's a small sample size again but 27th
so it's something to consider are the
play calls different we talked about
last night about the lack of that power
run game yes especially Billy Dee Dee if
LeSean McCoy and Damian Williams are
banged up your next running back is
Darwin Thompson who's a scat back so if
they're not able to pound the rock
inside the 20s against the Baltimore
Ravens team you might be able to move
like we might be getting a lot of yards
here just it might be a lot of Harrison
bucker and not a lot of hands up in the
air for the Chiefs
yeah and that's exactly right one of the
things that we know across the board is
that run
in the redzone is the most efficient
types of place that you can call down
there it's rushing the football down
there especially when you do it from
spread formations right don't use the
don't use the Steve Sarkisian jumbo
personnel groupings pack everybody in
dictate to the defense say these guys
might run let's bring on our jumbo and
then actually run the football out of
that right you want to pass out of heavy
sets down in the red zone you want to
run out of spread sets running is more
efficient than passing down there that's
one of the few times talk about that and
33% should know passing is far more
efficient across the board but when you
get down into the red zone that's one of
the times when I like running I like
running in short yardage in red zone now
warren likes running on third and short
fourth and short and in the red zone
especially if you're sneaking on those
third and fourth short and you love a
good quarterback sneak oh okay it's just
it's music to my eyes when I'm seeing it
there I'm like okay these guys
understand and I hate you I like music
guys there you go just blast it all over
you but the thing that I get frustrated
with when I see teams okay
they work so hard to get those nine
yards they're set up with third and one
or fourth and one and then they're that
close to like the first down marker
right and you got a quarterback and you
got an offensive line and all you got to
do either bull rush forward or jump and
hold the ball out something like that
well instead what to the coaches call
let's line up in shotgun oh my god five
yards back four yards back then let's
turn and hand the ball off to a running
back maybe who's even further behind us
or we'll throw the ball those are the
types of places you can call on a fourth
and five a fourth and six but you earned
those first nine yards to get there yes
take advantage of that and call a play
that's very successful for the 33% 85%
success rate when a quarterback runs the
football on a 31 or fourth and one Wow
since 2015 sixty-three percent success
rate if he takes the snap and hands it
back to his running back who's a few
yards behind him to try to get that
first down
that's over a 20% decrease in success
converting that down and distance that
there's no excuse for so when you're
watching a game on Sunday and it's third
and one and they decide to do a draw or
a
[ __ ] or god forbid a throw just know
that your coach is going against 85% an
85% success rate if he just falls
forward it doesn't even matter I'm you
do it twice
the Eagles did it twice on Sunday night
but it doesn't even matter who you're
running back is like it's not just the
great running quarterbacks that have
high conversion rates Tom Brady Drew
Brees like little guys big guys what
have you good conversion rates my three
least favorite things right now in the
NFL going in shotgun in third insurer or
fourth and short trying to block a great
pass rusher with a tight end Jimmy
Graham on Daniel hunter and whoever
Denver tried to put on Khalil Mack
sticks out to me and number three is
all-out blitzing on fourth down like
yeah let's give let's this is very easy
to talk about the Eagles here
let's give Matt Ryan one on ones in a
game-winning situation let's not make
him read the field and take an extra
second to figure out what defense were
playing know let's blitz and let him go
I get to lob it up and take all the
pressure off of me my three least
favorite things right now in the sport
Baltimore's offense against Kansas City
what do you see on that side of the
field well I see a Kansas City team
that's played okay defensively so far
and they have added pieces this year but
if I'm if I'm the Baltimore Ravens right
and we know that they said after week
one against the Dolphins that they
didn't even show hardly any of their
playbook in this game because he didn't
need to and we - they played the Arizona
Cardinals right and I know they like I
was surprised he didn't score more than
23 points at home obviously they only
want one for four inside the red zone a
lot of running the football from Lamar
Jackson in that game I think they got
some interesting things for this game
because if you think about the magnitude
of this game we're talking about three
games today but this particular game
could be for the team that is going to
be hosting you know that's going to be
that number two seed get that buy-in AFC
for the playoffs because New England
looks like they're dot number one seed
right now if the Ravens can go in there
and pull off this upset and claim
home-field advantage they got a
head-to-head
victory over they over the NC Chiefs
they're now three and OH on the season
and that's gonna be very valuable when
it comes down to who's gonna get that
number that number two seed in the first
round by in the postseason and also we
can we can wax poetic about Andy Reid I
believe hardball is right up there with
them nah I think Andy Reid is a he's
very special coach but in big games like
this I would take John Harbaugh all the
time you know also I want to say really
quick Tyree kill in that game against
the Ravens last year where the Chiefs
pulled it out eight catches a hundred
and thirty eight yards hundred thirty
nine yards seventeen point four not
having Tyree kill out there I think is a
massive massive loss for that team in a
matchup of this kind of magnitude four
o'clock game Saints at Seahawks we'll
start off with the Saints have the ball
against the Seahawks things that kind of
stuck out to me from an injury
standpoint no drew Brees obviously
Saints are putting their starting
linebacker Alex and Zolo knee on IR and
one of their wide receivers Keith
Kirkwood tray Quan Smith did not
practice Kirkwood on IR trade Quan Smith
didn't practice with a knee who is the
second who is a third wide receiver
right now behind Ted Ginn I don't even
know Sheldon Rankin's Andrus peat
limited practice for Seattle the four
guys that did not practice
Ethan Poe chick Nikko Thorpe their
corner Tedric Thompson their safety and
DJ Fluker all expected to play and pune
ford and ezekiel Anza are expected to
play this will be the first game for
ezekiel Anza pune ford had a great week
one missed week to apparently Pete
Carroll said he's coming up to buna
Ford's coming up to Pete Carroll on
going I'm playing on Sunday so New
Orleans have the ball we expect Sean
Payton to take a lot of shots here how
do these two teams match up when the
Saints have the ball taking on the
Seahawks in Seattle at 4 o'clock okay so
one of the things that is a little bit
frustrating it was more so frustrating
last season but is caring forward to
this year is some of the play calling in
Seattle and their emphasis on the run
game but one of the other things that
I've noted is their efficiency
and lack of a start in games especially
in that first quarter okay so if we look
at what Seattle has done in the first
quarter of games their success rate is
one of the worst in the NFL in fact it
is tied for the worst with Tampa Bay
they have a 29 percent success rate in
the first quarter that's terrible right
the league average is 48 percent success
rate there are 29 percent almost 20
percent worse we're expecting a slow
start out of Seattle I expect Seattle to
start off slow their game scripts have
not been very good they end up having
like a pretty even run pass split but
they have a 30% success rate when they
run the football
they run the football too often on early
downs try to establish the run try to
build out this mindset of what we're
gonna do here offensively which you've
got Russell Wilson I I totally don't
love that type of logic right and and
their passing has not been ideal either
only 5.3 yards per attempt however after
that they're much better they're in like
the forty seven percent on average
success rate over the course of the game
one of the things about the New Orleans
Saints is going to be interesting to see
how they do here but they actually start
out the game fairly well and they're
really good in the second quarter in
terms of their success rate Sean Payton
make some good adjustments after what he
sees on that first drive or to make some
good adjustments in that second quarter
their second quarter success rate is one
of the best in the NFL so what I'm
interested in seeing here is we talked
about Teddy Bridgewater yes and we
talked about how we don't have a lot of
confidence in Teddy but we think this is
a big game for him right but we also
talked about how we think that that
offense is in Sean Payton are going to
utilize some more trick plays a little
bit more Taysom Hill yes there's nothing
to lose here and if you think about it
when just like you're watching games
when is it most likely that trick plays
are going to occur the coaches typically
aren't saving these things deep in their
bag of tricks
to the fourth quarter unless it's a team
like the New England Patriots who sees
something as like oh let's add this even
then Patriots
throw from Edelman back to James white
first or second quarter
Kyle Shanahan all of his trick plays
against the Cincinnati Bengals first and
second quarter
you hit him early because they haven't
seen it all week and you punch them
right in the mouth and then the rest of
the game they're going what's about to
happen to us exactly and because what
are those teams doing those teams the
defense is preparing all week for what
you do this is what to expect when
they're lined up like this this is what
to expect that stuff is fresh in their
mind at the beginning of games and so
they're gonna play the tendencies the
defense is going to play the tendencies
more often in the beginning of games so
I expect if we're gonna see some trick
plays out of Sean Payton it's gonna come
in that first half and I expect if
Taysom Hill is going to be passing a
little ball a little bit more which the
Seahawks haven't seen you know it's
going to be in that first half okay so
Seahawks
start slow Saints start a little quicker
guess what that line is in the first
half what do we got Seattle - three I
could take the Saints plus three in the
first half and one of the benefits like
is is the ability to dip your toe in the
water see what it feels like and then
not have to worry about it after that
right and that's what things like do I
want to really be betting on Teddy
Bridgewater in his first start all four
quarters my fear is that I bet on the
Saints and Teddy has to drive down the
field in crunch time and I know that
he's really not going beyond 15 yards
with any comfort but if I commit the
first half which is more betting on Sean
Payton's Brian brain versus the vs.
Brian Schottenheimer is brain versus
Brian Shauna but also but also the
conservative nature of the Seahawks in
the first quarter yeah Pete Carroll's
influence as well yeah that's so so
anyways I think that's a pretty nice
pretty nice wager for you guys Warren
sharpest gave you all a gift and I'm
taking the gift I'm gonna send a text
message as soon as I get out of here
Sunday night game we talked about it
kind of earlier already did you have
anything else on Seahawks Saints by the
way Rams Browns Sunday Night Football
Browns coming off of a Monday night win
in which they didn't look good early and
then Odell had that huge play right down
the seam and they also had to play Luke
look did not practice it's likely that
Austin Blythe the starting guard for the
Rams and tight end Tyler Higbee who
apparently was coughing up blood during
the game will likely not play on Sunday
night Cleveland David and Joe ku got a
concussion and broke his wrist he's
definitely not playing five other guys
did not practice linebacker Christian
Kirksey right tackle Chris Hubbard
defensive tackle Larry
Eggman Joby and this all Wednesday so
it's we had to observe it and two
safeties Morgan Burnett and Darin
damarious Randall but Rashard Higgins
and Dontrelle Hilliard should come back
other than the 11 personnel and the do
the Rams defend 11 personnel really well
by the way yes okay is there anything
else 41 percent success rate against 11
personnel so the Browns are playing too
much 11 the Rams defend it really well
and the Browns offensive line stinks
okay good to note rams by the way Rams
against 11 they've allowed a 43 percent
success rate when you pass the ball
against um from 11 only six point three
yards per attempt a 66 passer rating no
touchdowns two interceptions what about
I you know I'm curious what is Shaun
McVeigh's personnel like because he was
so happy with 11:00 last year right what
has he been like so far this season
McVeigh is a guy that I'm he's a genius
I want to know what he's doing 82% 11
personnel this year so super high rates
again and then you run out of 11 a lot
though they're pretty balanced of 55%
past 45% run and but you talk about
Tyler Higbee
that's one of their tight ends they
don't like using two tight ends anyways
doesn't matter so you're gonna be down
him possibly what are we gonna get
probably more 11 personnel than we
expect it so we got two offenses that
are gonna utilize a lot of 11
personality but am I crazy
did did Cleveland when they were playing
Tennessee did they let up their big
plays in big packages or 11 big package
packages it was it was a lot of thee and
that's one of the reasons why on this
very show we talked I believe we talked
about it against the Jets the Jets use a
lot of 11 personnel Adam GaSe the
principal obsessed with 11 personnel so
I said even if they had their starting
quarterback in there right even if
Arnold was there this is still a not
very advantageous matchup for the Jets
because the Browns that were good
against the Titans from 11 where the
Titans were getting gashed a little bit
was I'm sorry where the Browns defense
was getting gashel but was from some of
that bigger sets the plays that looked
like run out of 12 but they're actually
passing the ball and the Jets weren't
able to do any of that
the Jets got pasted on Monday Night
Football now you've got the Rams who
don't utilize a lot of those heavier set
right use a lot of 11 so we got two
teams that have had decent success
defending 11 personnel going up against
one another and two teams that quite
honestly I I think across the board this
isn't just my opinion if you ask anybody
had the Rams as the Rams offense looked
as good as it did last year has the
Browns offense looked as good as what
you expected coming in from last year
that's an obvious no to obvious knows
where the offenses aren't looking as
good as they did last year Jared Goff
playing on the road where he's got awful
very bad home road splits and I expected
better from him last week at home he had
pretty good moments he had the the big
pass to cooks at the beginning looking
other than that it was a little quiet in
the first out of Cooper cup doing it
himself
Cooper Cup was getting open in the
secondary my big take has been we're
gonna get done Sunday at 1 o'clock and
we're gonna watch the 10th pick in the
draft
Patrick mahomes and the 32nd pick in the
draft Lamar Jackson go Wow
that's the future of the league and then
after Sunday night we're gonna look at
the number one pick in the draft Jared
Goff and the number one pick in the
draft Baker Mayfield and go that was
supposed to be the future of the league
I look at everything you're telling me
right now and I look at the Rams and the
mystique around them in the Browns the
mystique around them and I look at
currently on Thursday a line of 49 and I
go pound it the Rams have now huge holes
on their offensive line and miles
Garrett can do anything he wants the
Cleveland Browns have huge holes on
their offensive line and Aaron Donald
can do anything he wants
and both Jared Goff and Baker Mayfield
are abysmal under pressure yeah we
talked about bake
under pressure terrible Jared Goff the
same way yeah yeah we're giving out gold
right now we've never given out this
much stuff before I look it has it has
to win right it has four same course but
the thought process the logic is sound
and let's see where these lines move by
the time we get to Sunday mmm because I
think we're gonna have some some
examples where these lines are gonna go
the way we're suggesting that they go
okay so I'm gonna kind of go over some
of my super contest pics with you we're
gonna call crack is there any other
thing you want to get off your chest no
this is therapeutic for you know we
covered it I was really impressed the
one other thing that I think a lot of
people don't know about week one sorry
week two and the start of the season in
general is how efficient and we were
talking about this last night how
efficient the New York Giants offense
has been please let me just say I would
have been mad one time one of my picks
for the Super contest I'll start with
that is the New York Giants plus six and
a half at Tampa Bay I went into this
yesterday it was a line that was at four
and then went to six and a half and my
first reaction was you're telling me
that Eli is worth two and a half points
more than Daniel Jones I think you're
crazy the Giants in Week one move the
ball against the Dallas Cowboys except
Dallas scored five touchdowns and five
straight possessions and it was just
tighten tighten tighten tighten tighten
and guess what Tampa Bay has not done at
all feature their tight ends so we'll
see what happens with OJ Howard but the
other thing is is that when you said how
efficient the Giants have been it's
crazy well what do you got and you could
find this on sharp football stats calm
yeah that's it's not on sharp football
analysis calm this is sharp football
stats which is like a free-to-use
visualized data website everybody can do
tons of research there the New York
Giants this so far this season the
number one most successful rushing
offense in the NFL they're posting a 62%
rushing success rate the league average
is 49%
there are 62% they're averaging seven
point six yards a carry it's small
sample size yeah
that's what we keep trying to knock into
people says if you dismiss everything
saying it's a small sample size I Got
News for you by the time you get the
week 15 overall being considered it's
still small sample size there's only 16
games so you better start figuring out
how to utilize the data even though
you've got a small sample size 6
62% success what we're in they run the
football 51 percent success rate when
they pass that still 10th best in the
league overall this is a top 10 offense
in terms of efficiency New York Jon New
York Giants miss Eli with Eli everybody
thinks that ok this is gonna be a
downgrade because we're bringing in
Daniel Jones because he hasn't played
and so many people talk trash about
Daniel Jones right heading into the
draft and that whole process yeah and
the reality is this Giants offense has
been pretty good
it's only gonna get better with a
quarterback to actually running a guy
like Jameis Winston that offense doesn't
seem to be in total sync yes look at how
bad Cam Newton played in that game on
Thursday night and this team almost was
able to win that game yes I guess bad is
like he was playing clearly not healthy
you don't have all these weapons out
there III think it's really gonna be
interesting I'm really looking forward
to watching that Giants game so one of
mine is gonna be Giants plus six and a
half pounds like you're in agreement
another one I'm gonna do is because the
line went from four to one and a half so
I'm gonna do what I learned from last
week I'm gonna take the Colts one and a
half at home I I'm going to watch the
injury report if Marlin Mack is not
healthy to go I'm probably gonna get too
afraid of that because Wilkins had a
nice big run last week but I'm a little
bit concerned but from what I saw from
Atlanta and their injuries with Kayla
McGarry and also I know Matt Ryan's good
in domes but he's not that great on the
road I'm kind of like in that Baltimore
I'm gonna go with Baltimore plus six and
a half at Kansas City I think that that
to me the line should be a four where I
think it started with a lot of people
six and a half I would have loved it at
a seven if it in real life if it can get
to a seven dear God please
six-and-a-half though I have to take it
I'm gonna take Detroit plus six at
Philadelphia Matt Stafford since he's
been on the Lions
the Lions are three and elegance the
spread in Philly the home-field
advantage
Philly three and six against the spread
in their last nine home games and also
as an Eagles fan I know this and in the
stats packed it up Owen five against the
spread in their last five september
games the Eagles have started slow the
last few years and then Doug Peterson
just like he does every season goes what
the hell are we doing let me fix figure
this out and then they start hitting
their their stride all the injuries
everyone chronically hates Matt Stafford
so I'm gonna use their chronic hate
against them and I think that they're
just really banged up so I'm going those
for then I was stuck
do I go Jets plus two and A two and a
half I don't know I like Buffalo a lot
but the six is too much after talking to
you I'm good I think I'm gonna go
chargers minus three against Houston I
don't feel great about this game because
I know that Houston can put up points
but what I'm betting against is I it was
a five and a half point line I believe
the Chargers thoroughly outplay the
Detroit Lions but I do not believe the
box score represents that I believe that
the Texans did not outplay the Jaguars
even though they got that win and the
only touchdown they got was because they
forced a fumble on Gardner Minshew
inside the ten and then punched it in I
know that the Chargers defense has not
been great from an efficiency standpoint
but the Chargers are coming off a loss
where they're ready to take everybody's
head off and the Texans in my mine are
coming off a win that they might feel a
little bit confident about and they
should not so this is a little bit of
left go playing inside the minds and I
want a desperate Philip Rivers Philip
Rivers desperate with Austin Eckler and
Justin Jackson and Keenan now I'm just
I'm going how do we feel about those I'm
taking a lot of points this week you are
if if I just can add something that we
didn't a game we didn't talk about we
touched on some of these but the game
that you're looking out with the
charters and the Texans one of the
interesting things there is you talked
about a quarterback who could be under a
little bit of pressure you know deshaun
Watson he got banged around a little bit
week one against the New Orleans
he's a stud so he powered through it
yeah but it's very interesting to watch
the and think about the ends in same
sitting in LA
the Chargers coming in applying that
edge pressure trying to keep him inside
the pocket a little bit more collapse
that pocket down on a somewhat weak
offensive line of the Houston Texans
playing on the road that's adventurous I
feel [ __ ] good by the way I am six
and four to three in two weeks which not
where I want to be I wish I was more
than the eight into range but I'll take
six and four you need to take it because
it's a contest you've got the
opportunity to get hot yes you can't and
I've been on the good side for most of
them you can't play yourself out of it
early and you're not doing that I was
choking with Ingmar beforehand that we
always like to find excuses and the
games we lost and we we never look at
the games we won we go oh no I had that
the entire time so let's let's give
crack a call bill crack and Berger want
to say this also before he comes on
download the crack wins app you'll get
the crack men's weekly picks along with
great betting tips and insider content
and of course Warren sharp sharp sharp
analysis sharp football analysis card
open house to be honest I'm subscribed
and I've been enjoying not just the
betting but also the fantasy it's helped
me out a lot in DFS but that noise is
Bill cracking burger the crack man how
you feeling buddy hey are you guys doing
alright how the radio show go good you
know I just had a good just had a good
show and we talked about all different
subjects today most about going to
dinner with Bob Merriman and ordering
liver on in some small my hall table up
you Bob Arum the boxing promoter that's
famous he ordered yeah and onions yes we
went to Piero's which is a big famous
restaurant out here and I was just
making fun of them but I'm and you know
listen I'm not make us one of them under
saying onions red cayenne restaurant no
it sounds exactly what like a old-school
boxing guy would order though I like
living I mean to toughen up my insights
to get ready for the world yeah I like
that
right liver and onions reminds me I
think it was like Doug funnie or Rocko's
Modern Life one of those cartoons like
the word
you get Rugrats like liver and onions
crack you ready for my pips
oh yeah yeah and I have a little
opinions on my own this week oh yeah
perfect perfect I'm taking a lot of
points this week my five Detroit +6 at
Philly start all right with that public
team the Eagles I actually expected to
build off you to take more money here
and looks like it opened up seven and a
half went down to sit that six here in
Nevada now at a lot of books
yeah I'm not excited about I'm not
excited about losing the number I
thought I was gonna get it at seven but
I'm still gonna take it at six I'm
taking Baltimore plus six and a half at
Kansas City crack what do you think
that's uh Kansas City's home opener
place is going to be crazy I mean you
have to MVP candidates there without
both quarterbacks of the quarterback of
each team that's good that's gonna be a
tough place I know it's a lot of points
I'm probably gonna use it on my card
also on on the West Gate contest is it
six and a half it is six and a half yeah
because this six is now the sharper
sports books offshore our six dog money
which means yet too late you know a
dollar fifty on the dog at some of the
sharper spots and I respect oh it scares
the hell I have no problem with that I'm
just afraid that you know they have the
holes goes home and it's gonna fix that
the crowds gonna be crazy there so we'll
see what happens though yeah I'm just
I'm a biased Baltimore supporter and six
and a half with that team against anyone
until I get proven wrong I'm going to
continue to bet them in D minus one and
a half hosting Atlanta the number went
from four to one and a half and I think
that's too much of a movement both both
dome teams there I would have to you
know we were high on Warren I'll tell
you this he was pretty high on Indy
before the quarterback situation there
and I'm still rooting for them we need
them I I need them to win some games
here I need them to home for the season
alone tonight's total I am I'm putting
my money on Daniel Jones and I'm going
Giants plus six and a half at Tampa
you're gonna go with the new quarterback
and I am you know I don't think if you
if you were to ever tell anyone that
Tampa Bay would be a a six and a half
point favorite verse to join I mean they
would exactly though you know it's uh
I'm hoping the team gets behind him and
and and I would be in agreeance with
that pick on this one crack we've talked
about this before but teams tend to
rally around that quarterback when
they're replacing a key player like a
quarterback the whole team buys in and
this is something that crack and I have
discussed before buys in and steps up
their game knowing that they got to do
everything in their power to help out
this guy isn't that funny
my last one crack is I'm gonna go
chargers minus three hosting Houston I
mean they're both awful struggling uh
yes last weekend
it's a it's an interesting game it
really is so it is minus three on the
con that the content have a line so
that's what I got yeah that's what the
contest was well mathematically it's a
great pick and based on it being three
minus three minus twenty at almost every
single shop it means the money is coming
on that's under charges
I would I would tend to agree I hate to
agree with all your picks but I would
agree with tests this is not like to be
the contrarian side I'm glad you stayed
away from those giants those giant
spreads the Dallas and a normal games
the two things Krakus I've been I've
been paying a lot of attention to you
and Warren and so I'm trying to focus on
games where I think there's value it was
there was there any other ones that I
missed that you have your eye on that
you can talk to the 33% that they should
get oh speaking of which I got three
different people that said they wanted
to know what the 33 percent was you just
tell me I know what the 30 the 30
percent misses when when I lost when
Sims moved on and vendrick moved on and
I had 33 percent of the podcast and I
said let's give it to the listeners and
we've kind of rallied around that
because this is not a show to make me
feel good or a show just so I could talk
at the show where the the audience is
the community and that can be
now owns 33% of the show now I own 34 I
just want everyone to know that I have a
1% majority stake but I'm giving it to
33 it's like right now
Warren's got 33 but when you came on
right now crack you have 16.5 sure to
see you know I like a 116 point five
percent a lot of percentage points yeah
but yeah so who do you like crowd San
Fran San Fran I think San Fran goes home
and I like to see what's going to happen
to the San Fran it's Berg so I think I'm
gonna you know you these contents are so
hard to call the five sides in the NFL
every week oh my god I struggle to do it
myself I'm probably gonna pick San Fran
there I think San Fran goes there and
Pittsburgh's in disarray there there I
know they're under like warrants of a
new quarterback we're gonna support him
but I think San Fran I like San Fran a
little bit and believe it or not I hate
to go here but I have to I've four years
I've watched the Jets play knowing on
very close to spreads oh and I was an
amoeba getting extra extra points here
and the Jets have taken some money out
here in Nevada there's 21 and a half now
at the sharper sports books and being
2023 up there there is a couple books so
it's 20 threes so I kind of lean towards
taking points like that with the Jets
and crack I'm probably gonna use them
but I am I am also going to use a couple
of year games though just to let you
know I am I like Baltimore I like
awesome crack you are the man make sure
that you guys download the crack wins
app he gives out some free picks he
gives some betting tips and to be honest
he's just a good [ __ ] and I like
him crack appreciate your brother you
too man but you know it's funny as
cracks one of those guys that tells you
to be safe and I know that he genuinely
means it he actually cares about you
so crackers go in San Francisco and you
know what I will say this certain teams
when the quarterback comes in where it's
a Daniel Jones or a Teddy I could see
the team rallying but there are certain
teams like the Steelers where it
probably feels like their seasons coming
to an end well they're a little bit like
[ __ ] well here's the thing with the
Steelers there is a little bit of
glimmer of hope Minka Fitzpatrick why
would a team tray for Minka Fitzpatrick
if they're throwing in the towel on the
season and
in mason rudolph as your quarterback i
think that move i didn't agree with that
move
i mean this is a good time did you
suffer i did not agree with that move i
thought they should have kept the
defense as is it's problematic
let mason rudolph has his have his
growing pains hopefully take a top ten
pick and get your quarterback on the
future what they're deciding to do is
maybe masons that guy but the guy's a
third-round picked the odds that he is
gonna be that guy is is unlikely
especially if he hasn't like proven it
isn't already topped if he hasn't popped
so lets you know they're going with
let's see what mason rudolph does we're
gonna get ben next year we're gonna have
Minka our defense is going to be better
and we're gonna have been back I don't
know if an older been off of a shoulder
surgery or elbow surgery either is gonna
be the same type of guy but like they
are still I think bought into the fact
that we're making a run we're making a
run because they probably don't have as
much respect for the Baltimore Ravens in
the Marg accent you know that's a rival
and the spangles are terrible and the
Browns not looking as good they think
they've got a shot when's the last time
the Steelers haven't gone for it right
that's not in their DNA no to pack it in
no so I don't I don't I don't anticipate
the Steelers coming out here with a lack
of effort the other thing that the
Steelers probably are not going to do is
sleep walk we see them go on some of
these West Coast trips and just totally
pack it in they don't even show up
because they're off of a couple wins and
then they have this brighter but bent
has a terrible performance out there I'm
not saying this dealers are gonna cover
or they won't all I'm saying is that I
think they're still not like they're not
throwing in the towel on the season just
because of been I want to I want to wrap
it up with this is the analytics
community right now is everybody just
over the moon with what the Dolphins are
doing because the Dolphins are doing the
very smart play where they have now like
five first-round picks in the next two
years and the old school football
community is going this is embarrassing
you're a JV team but as the analytics
community right now like doing the hora
and lifting up people on chairs like
like what is it like from your
perspective I'm glad that they're going
all-in because I want to see it happen
so many teams
do the rebuild because they've gone five
and you know their five and eleven
they're six and ten for a couple of
years and they're like we need to
rebuild so they do a couple of minor
things and and and not anywhere close to
what the Dolphins are doing and then
they go seven and nine they go nine and
seven they make the wild card game maybe
they win a game but that's the ceiling
right we haven't seen a team like try to
rebuild and then go all the way to the
top and that's what the Dolphins are
doing and the reason why I think it's a
smart strategy is because look at where
Patrick mahomes was drafted right like a
look at where Russell Wilson which often
some of these quarterbacks okay they're
very there are misses above those guys
on other quarterbacks that are higher
drafted that were viewed as better
prospects and teams drafted those guys
and missed the point is you want shots
because even if you have a number one
pick or the number three pick that does
not guarantee that you're going to hit
on these guys it's very difficult to
project these guys out of college to
have success in the NFL so he will offer
any type of consistency you want those
arrows in your quiver that you can pull
out and the more arrows the more likely
you're to hit bull's eyes and that's
what they need to do and that's what
they're doing yes I hope it ends up
paying off at the end of the day they're
making the right moves now what they
need to do next is make the right
decisions on those picks and that's a
whole different topic the analytics
community guys that need to get involved
to help them make those right picks but
they're at least acquiring the pieces
for them to use to build that capital
and to all of the chrome agenda football
fans that are saying who's gonna want to
go to Miami what kind of culture are you
building hi I rooted for the Sixers and
for four years I heard you guys talk
about no free agents gonna want to come
and our culture is gonna suck we have
one of the best cultures in the NBA
right now because we build it from the
ground up and we were able to secure
free agents because Al Horford
I'm sorry burr decided it was better
culture to play with the Philadelphia
76ers than it was for the Boston Celtics
I don't even know if that's accurate I
just kind of want to take a shot of you
because I know you have to watch me back
there but well you bring in guys and you
build around them and you start from the
bottom and it's it's it's just it's very
chroma genie to say that this is gonna
backfire in your face
Landon Collins signed with the
Washington Redskins because they offered
him 84 million dollars he did not go
because the culture was phenomenal in
Washington if you have salary cap and
you have draft picks you have ammunition
and that's all you're trying to do
because you're not gonna win the Super
Bowl with Ryan Tannehill and Kenny
Stills and Laremy Tunsil you're [ __ ]
nut so let's start over from the bottom
and I got news for the other teams
around the NFL that are like this is bad
for the league this is not the right way
to do it
guess what most teams in the league are
not optimizing their odds of winning
themselves so look in the mirror before
you point the finger and number two it's
their team if they want to do this and
see the repercussions from the fans and
what-have-you yes that's their desire to
do that and I'm gonna let them do what
they think is in their best interest yes
to achieve their goal which is not to
have a 9 & 7 team anymore it's to win
the Super Bowl in a few years and so
we'll see if it works and the thing
that's valuable for them is they have an
owner that loves to take something in an
in a system that is seemingly
unchangeable and completely erase
something and then build up from the
ground up and then change the landscape
of that system he just did that to
Hudson Yards in Manhattan he's okay with
blowing up a section of the system and
then building it from the ground up and
going I have my own city within this
city I don't that was very Colin Cowherd
of me I'm trying some [ __ ] out of even
Ross good luck Warren you're the [ __ ]
man great having you in the city Eggbert
thank you for all this Nick
everybody in the back I'll even know if
mixed factors probably Matt great [ __ ]
to the 33% good luck with your bets if
you don't have the money don't make the
[ __ ] bets play along with mine and
ride that wave okay let's be smart love
you guys holler at you later
[Music]